c'est toi
c'est toi assis à côté des corps at war
on va refaire tout ça beaucoup du mail
sur la couleur ça ce ver ne plaît pas
aux gens ça c'est parce qu'on avait
beaucoup de maisons des nausées donc on
va réparer tout ça tire et santé sacs à
dos et se sera passé le joli cv scène
laurent boulet
vous êtes définitif attendait un petit
peu attendait de voir c'est vachement
bien
j'ai pas pris une couleur très très
belle parce que je sais que des buttes
shot mais ce sera toujours moins bien
que ton verre tiens mon petit bout lee
continue
bon écoute mais l'hymne qui peut aider
boullier laurent bon l'émission
commencera quand le décor sera
entièrement repeints il te manque
toujours un pinceau à toi chez vous si
vous aimez le vert vous tapez 1
si vous aimez le rose vous tapez 2 et
laurent les résultats sur son appareil à
sms catherine commence à s'énerver
l'heure on dit qu'il faut que tu ailles
ce soir ça les nerfs si je ressens
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inler du tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu